and your life chairman thank you
good evening and welcome to this
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
as the crime and disorder committee
on thursday the 11th of march 2021.
my name is councillor vanessa bell and i
am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on 4th of april in response to the
covid19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please can i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
the meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating a wish to raise a point of
order
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or
any other purpose when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now if i may ask officers and other
speakers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves
please starting with mr holmes
good evening members richard holmes
director of service delivery
thank you mr holmes mr clark
good evening members uh spencer clark
i'm the community safety manager
at moulton district council thank you mr
clark you're fairly faint i don't know
if you could
um turn your volume up a little bit
possibly
uh chief inspector scott haynes
good evening members chief inspector
state scott haynes chancellor maldon
district commander
good evening and thank you for joining
us chief inspector miss bird
hey good evening members tara bed i'm
kitty clark for this evening's meeting
thank you
thank you miss bird i believe we have uh
inspector first of all here as well
for me good evening i'm
uh inspector thurston i'm
that's all right took over a few months
ago and i'm just here really to sort of
listen and
see what's going on thank you for
joining us
inspector thurston are there any other
officers present
yes good evening members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
good evening mr dudson
good evening members damon geller lead
specialist community service delivery
good evening mr keller anybody else
okay before i call on the client to take
the roll call of committee members
can i ask those counsellors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
i don't think we've got any chairman oh
are we not miss bird that
makes a change thank you um could you
please now carry out a roll call of
committee members to confirm who is in
attendance
yes of course members if you could just
indicate you're here when i call your
name please
starting with councillor bastinger
please yeah good evening i'm present
evening thank you councillor miss beale
councillor brian beale
that's the bell you're here
mrs fleming present thank you tara
councillor mays
president tara thank you councillor
morley
present tara just i lost you and i'm
back again thank you
thank you councillor morris hello hello
hello
what's all this thing it's uh council
morris is here
thank you very much that ends the real
cool thank you chairman
thank you very much uh tara with thin on
the ground
tonight my happy apologies for absence
please
yes chairman apologies we received from
councillor duik thank you
thank you thank you very much tara which
brings us on to item three the minutes
of the 22nd of october 2020 meeting
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 22nd of october
2020
found on pages 5 to 10 are approved as a
true and accurate record
i so move if you wish to second that
motion please unmute your microphone and
state your name now
do i have a second uh counselor believe
that was counsellor maze
thank you um if any member wishes to
raise any matter of
accuracy please use the hands up
function to indicate and i
can't see any hands up so
i will take that as a no tara can you
advise if any other member has indicated
a wish to speak please no chairman no
not aware of anyone else wanting to
speak
thank you thank you sarah
members can we take these minutes by a
cent please will be happy to do so
great thank you thank you very much
so item four disclosure of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
do we if any member has any interest to
declare please use the hands up function
now to indicate
and i would vote and advise you to speak
invite you to speak sorry sometimes this
evening
no hands up
tara can you advise if any other members
indicated a wish to speak a champion uh
councillor morris got his hand up
i do apologize that hasn't you haven't
popped up on my screen counselor maurice
go ahead
how could you miss me guys um sorry
chair i did just uh wish to know have we
got
anyone from the democratic alliance
group in tonight
um sarah if you can confirm i don't
believe we
have councillor morris no chairman i
don't believe we have either
no no councillor boyce no councillor
juic
thank you thank you thank you
councillor morris um
item five public participation and i can
realize that
just before you move on
thank you i do apologize i don't seem to
be getting the hands
up on uh on my um
computer tonight so i do apologize so
if you could actually advise me if
anybody does because
they're not showing on my on my laptop
that's the fleming i do apologize
that's all right um chad i was just
looking at the minutes
and actually i think the committee um
we've had a meeting since 22nd of
october haven't we
we have have yeah so
um
thank you very much tara thank you for
that and
uh thank you councillor fleming oh yeah
your hand pops up
then finally just when you're about to
pop it down again
um okay so
yeah we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
so that brings us on to item number six
mould district community safety
partnership update
so this is found on pages 11
to 50 of your agenda pack and in a
moment i will call on the officer to
present this item
members a reminder if you wish to speak
on this item please make this known
by using the hands up function within
this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points
clear and succinct so if i could hand
over to you
please mr clark that would be lovely
thank you very much chair um i have
provided a
gender item in advance at the meeting um
but as discussed at the chairman's
briefing to make the
uh topic slightly more interesting i'm
going to share a presentation with
members
which will be uh similarly aligned to
the actual committee report um if you
just uh
bear with me for one second um thank you
and thank you for your reports um mr
clark thank you for that
hopefully members will be able to um
see this
okay is that sharing okay everyone
it is brilliant okay first steps down
then thank you
so um so i'll introduce myself first uh
my name is spencer clark
i'm the community safety manager at
moulton district council
and uh i've just got a few slides to
show you some of the work which the
partnership's been delivering
in the last year or so so i'll move on
to the next slide
um i know some of the elected members
are relatively new
um to this so i thought it'd be useful
just to explain
about the community safety partnership
and what the statutory duties of the
partnership are
so uh firstly uh um the the reason we do
this is because of the crime and
disorder act
1998 and uh the partnership isn't just
molden district council and essex police
who's here tonight
so the other response to authorities are
people like
health so medicine ccg a probation
service sort of an episode a national
probation service or essex community
rehabilitation company
essex fire and rescue service and
uh essex county council as well so uh
members can invite any of those actual
responsibilities
along to these sessions for scrutiny and
on other occasions we've had
some really interesting topics from uh
probation
and health delivered in the past so just
to flag that up
how we what we have one of our statutory
duties each year is to produce what's
called a strategic assessment
and that is getting all of the
information from all of those statutory
partners together
to assess the crime needs of malden
district and how we can
deliver against those and uh what more
importantly it does it enables us to
deliver some priorities each year and
these priorities are agreed
by all of those responsible authorities
and from that we produce what's called a
partnership plan
which is in the appendices for members
to view
and the necessary financial monitoring
of that plan
um when we talk about community safety
it's not just about crime
uh what we also look at is uh public
perceptions and public opinions because
sometimes people can feel
unsafe and it's our role to try and
tackle that and we also have a duty to
face the public and as most of the
members know um
we tend to do this as part of the police
fire and crime conditions public event
as well
so it's usually uh the police
commissioner the district commando
myself and some of the other partners
and last year's one was a really good
event because it enabled out to
get out to a much wider audience by
using their
zoom and a facebook live link um
other duties are we have to do two
presentations a year to over in scrutiny
this is one of them the other one was
done in october and uh
and there's also another range of things
which we work around like the
things like preventing violent extremism
domestic abuse and modern
day slavery and human trafficking and a
lot of the work we do nowadays
is very much focused around the
anti-social behavior crime and policing
act 2014.
so just back to our priorities which are
which are highlighted
on um page 11
of the actual report um and how we come
about
these so these priorities what we used
last year
20 20 21 sorry can i just sorry
i do apologize um
no difference no
it's very strange um do you want me to
put it up spencer
yeah do you mind tara yeah you stopped
sharing your screen i'll put mine up
thank you very much no worries sarah
thank you
sorry i'm smiling because we discussed
spencer the potential of this happening
just before the meeting
so has that made any difference as far
as ever is
not ready yeah she can just stop sharing
and then i can
[Music]
oh counselor anne beale has just joined
the meeting welcome
councillor bill yeah i've been here
about five or ten minutes
but you've just popped up
sorry about this guys my whole system's
sort of crashing here
right we're going to be having some
technical issues members and
officers tonight right is that unshared
my screen now
yeah right okay
there we go is that better
that's great
okay okay back to you mr clark
i think okay right
apologies about that so um um so yeah
just finished on the statutory duties if
we go to the next slide then please tara
and uh just talking about the priorities
and
how how we how we decide these
priorities each year is by strategic
assessment
so we look at lots of different crime
types um to try and deliver against that
um so um the ones we've got at the
moment you see a tackling crime
and reducing reoffending driving down
anti-social behavior in public places
identifying and supporting vulnerable
people and
some of the other sort of work which we
do in different areas um
right i'm just having to amend what i've
got on the screen here
because it's not actually probably right
so i'm doing it for my
my desktop now so um and
the other one we've got is increasing in
confidence in identifying
and reducing rural crime and the other
one around promoting
and uh road safety and challenging
irresponsible driving
so next slide please tara um what i
thought it'd be useful to do for members
is to try and just do a little bit of
horizon scanning about what's coming in
the future
and more importantly what the impact of
kobit 19
has had on the world of community safety
now i'm not going to talk too much about
crime because chief inspector is going
to talk about that
later day but um areas where we have
seen increases and these were expected
increases around
domestic abuse lots of people being
locked up in the same household and not
being able to
move in the lockdown measures and accept
in extreme cases
increases in anti-social behavior and
that's probably
more down to people becoming
less less tolerant with their neighbours
um
as you can imagine so we've certainly
seen issues around
issues around that so
um other other areas where we
we're also beginning to see um
sorry that's it apologies my screen's
going a bit funny at this end
other areas where we also begin to see
some some worrying concerns around
mental health
and particularly around the emotional
health and well-being
of young people so through through my
role with modesto's children's
partnership board we're certainly doing
a lot of work around that at the moment
um other areas are increased alcohol
consumption
um whilst people aren't going to pubs
there's a lot of drinking going on at
home
doing lots of pressures on people
whether it's through work whether it's
through homeschooling et cetera
and things like that sorry so we've lost
um we've lost the presentation again
i didn't want to interrupt your flow but
we're all watching ourselves now and the
your presentation was far more
interesting
sorry no offense
i'll pause for a second i'll have a
quick drink of water while
tara's putting the screen back up
thank you tara much appreciated no
problem um
so as i was saying about um some of the
areas which the impact have been there's
been quite a lot of increase in scams
so i've been doing a lot of work with
our neighborhood watch about
notifications around that
conspiracy theories uh lots of things
going on i mean the
the world's gone slightly strange when
you think about what's been happening
particularly in other countries but lots
of conspiracy theories around
uh vaccines for example and there's been
a bit of an increase in domestic
extremism
you know um you've had we've been in
lockdown for a year now
people have been locked down for a year
particularly young people were
accessing extreme material online and
have been cases of young people being
radicalized
as a result of that so there's lots of
things we need to keep an eye on as a
result of covid
and some of this will be years to come
before we actually see the impact of
some of them
um i think would be useful to flag up to
members free bills which are coming in
in the coming year so the domestic abuse
bill 2020 that actually comes in this
year
i think it has royal ascent soon so we
don't know the exact duty but the duty
for
local authorities will be strengthening
it strengthen the duty to protect victim
domestic abuse
for statutory agencies so i think one of
the areas that might come to mold and
district accounts will be around safe
accommodation
and there has been some funding
allocations to both essex county council
and all of the districts around safe
accommodation so hopefully that will
put us in good stead for the future and
that another duty which will be coming
in probably in 2022 now is the serious
violence duty
so um statutory agencies of which modern
district
council will be one of them will have a
duty to have serious violence as a
priority
you already know we've got violent crime
as a priority
and uh there'll be uh opportunity what
we'll have to do is engage and share
information with partners
i mean i'm not sure what difference that
will make to holding because we've been
doing it for a long time anyway
we already worked really closely with
the essex violence and vulnerability
unit
and we've been sharing a e data with
broomfield hospital for about six or
seven years now
so but that will become a duty and
they'll also uh i think it's only
announced a couple of days ago about the
syrian serious violence reduction orders
will be coming in
um finally on this but this page is the
protect duty
so consultation started on the project
protect duty
a couple of weeks ago and the
consultation closes
in around about things the third or
fourth of july this year
so what that's about it's really what's
going to be coming out of the manchester
inquest
so it's going to be how we look after
and protect
our public in crowded places going
forward
so that's going to be an opportunity
next slide pleader uh talent
um just saying a little bit about um
how the partnership works um
and the structure of it so we've
uh we work very closely with essex
police
um uh that community safety partnership
hub's been going since uh
march 2019 i'm sitting in at the moment
so that's where i am i'm
working out of the hub at the moment as
we speak um and
we have what we call monthly partnership
meetings with the wider group so all of
the other groups like the other agencies
which support us
have a task in meeting so in the hub
we have the community policing team we
also have the essex
violence and vulnerability unit and what
we're looking to do is introduce
other partners into the pub uh future
date so people like the youth service
people we have day-to-day sort of
workings with that works really really
well and it's made a massive difference
to the way
community safety partnerships work um
in moldham we have the local response
team
so the 24 7 response team have been
based at malden
district council since october 2018
when the police station closed and that
works really well
and we're looking to get more of a
community policing footprint into the
offices
in the near future we have quite a lot
of forums with schools
so we work with schools really closely
we work with our social
landlords really closely and we have
forums around mental health
and neighborhoods and communities so we
have really good links to our
communities and neighborhoods
um another area where we've seen a
really
improvement is the work we do with
social care so this afternoon i've been
on a two-hour call with social care
looking at some of the vulnerable areas
of the district and the
work we do with the youth offending
teams and the youth service
i thought it would also be useful to
give give members an idea and a flavor
of
all of the other meetings which we
attend and this is just
just a small amount of them so say for
essex i'm the vice
chair of safer essex so that's the
umbrella for
community safety across the whole of
essex where all of the partners
meet and look at strategies and sign off
for some of the policies
uh more more local level we have the
essex community safety network
the prevent board which i also sit on
mace
is missing and child exploitation so
this is where we consider uh high-risk
young people and more importantly what
measures
we put in place to protect them the bap
is the behavior and attendance
partnership
that's where we look at young people on
the cusp of offending
so rather than put them into sorts but
special measures we look at things like
managed move to other schools first
that works really well um as i explained
before about mid essex children's
partnership board i'm
vice chair of that group that's where we
look at the health related
outcomes for young people so loads of
work going on around mental health for
young people at the moment
and a few of the slightly more uh
diverse ones s
eastern sixty which is a member of the
special interest group encounter on
extremism
so i've been doing a lot of work around
that at the moment and
some of the influences which come into
essex
and things like safeguarding adults
board but there's many more many more
meetings which the groups
actually work alongside so if we go on
to the next slide please
um so what i want to do is just flag up
only a few of the sort of works we've
been doing this year
and i think one of the real ones is a
really
useful to explain to members about this
one was a crucial crew
so we've been delivering crucial crew
for years now it's usually been a
face-to-face contact
but we've made the decision this year
it's going to be difficult getting into
schools
and it's not just malden's gonna have
those problems so claire and my team
had to think about other ideas what we
could do um
we're looking to tackle the main sort of
issues again like exploitation
and uh what we decided to do this year
we've commissioned a drama company
called tick box productions
and they're going to deliver a recorded
drama
on uh to young people and we talk about
year six
so it's a transition year when young
people move from
primary to secondary education and uh
it's going to have a
interactive breakout session so what
will happen
is the schools will have this material
with a 45-minute drama
in advance and then
they'll view that a day or the morning
of that particular session
and then in the interactive session with
the with the workshop they'll be with
the actors and they'll have the
opportunity to change
the ending of the story which will make
it truly interactive with young people
so you know it'll be what would happen
if the person
said this what would happen if they
wanted to speak to the teacher
so so we're really pleased about that
and we've actually got a malden teacher
who's writing a lesson plan for it
and it's the complement the vvu's
e-learning module which went live
yesterday so professionals and teachers
can now
learn about exploitation for the
e-learning module
so initially when we looked at this it
was just malden
and and trump said well work as well and
then uh we spoke about
it all the other community safety
partnerships in essex
they effectively bit our hands off so
we've got ten of the csps in essex
interest in it now and it's going to
potentially go out to 16 000 students
uh by the end of july so it's a really
good news story from for malden
um one of the other things we're working
on as we get into secondary education
for year seven and eight
it's a project we're working on with
storylab which is part of anglia ruskin
university
uh the cambridge campus where we're
going to be looking to deliver
an immersive virtual reality experience
for young people
around exploitation so again that that's
a really interesting bit of work
we hope to have it complete by september
for the newer
academic year so again just to highlight
in a couple of projects we're doing
there
from the next slide please tara
um i highlighted uh uh in the pack
of some work we've done around domestic
abuse um
we've done the when i say we claire done
a session for
the parish clerk's forum um uh about a
month ago
because they're really keen to learn
about what services were available
uh i put claire's uh four slides into
one slide here
so just an idea of how people can access
the services through the compass
and uh what our duties are what it is
useful to point out i know some of the
members here tonight have actually
attended the training
was uh we've been delivering the j9
training to staff and elected members
and we've also now on the 30th of march
got a community j9
so if any members of the community want
to learn and
gain awareness around domestic violence
that's available to them now
so if we go on to the next slide please
tara
okay th this slide is just to highlight
some of the other projects we've been
doing
um you're all familiar with our
community engagement offices and what an
excellent role they do
in the district um truecam is one of the
projects they do where they do
speed enforcement over and above what
the police actually
do that's been really good i've been
doing this for a number of years now
the old camera is getting a bit old now
so the partnership has
agreed to fund a new high-tech camera
out of their reserves so they'll be
getting a new present to
do some added enforcement uh uh in the
next financial year but they also do an
excellent job
uh working with other agencies
so uh people like uh essex police raw
engagement team
the environment agency they do some
joint working with the youth service
and they also do the just play football
um at the plume school and then
southminster at some nights
so it's just a bit about the community
engagement offices
um at the last uh scrutiny meeting i
streamed live from the cctv control room
if you recall
um that comprehensive system uh went
live on the first of july
um monitored at the champs at cctv
control room
and you'll see that um from the figures
i put in the actual report
there's actually something some really i
think we've had over
over 70 uh instants now which has
enabled
uh various incidents but it's not just
been about crime
it's also been about protecting and
finding missing persons
we've monitored monitored river levels
through storm surges
so it's been really useful for lots lots
of reasons and
also doing things like pedestrian
accounts and traffic counts
in the high street which has enabled us
to look at um how
how we can reopen the high street in a
safe
and appropriate manner um
one thing we're looking to introduce and
i know damian geller's on the call
tonight as well
who's been doing a lot of the work
around this is uh the introduction of a
public space protection order
um for malden prom hive key the high
street and burnham riverside park
we are in the consultation stage for
this uh so we're looking to
um how we can
to track the use of uh alcohol in the
parks and uh
and drugs particularly uh nitrous oxide
canisters
so that public space protection order to
come the consultation should
hopefully start in the next week or so
it's a six week
consultation period and uh i do urge
everyone to have their say on that
so it's something that we're looking to
introduce but realistically if you look
at the time frames in place
um because once we finish consultation
it has to go through
quite a few other processes you'll
probably be looking at around about
early autumn before it could go into
place
um another useful project which i
thought would be my
because it's worth flagging up because
again this is a first for moulding and
it's uh
cool eyes on this morning with some of
our other partners
uh that is a piece of work which we've
done with the design council
and we produced a screening tool in
molden
for young young people so again it's
year six
and it's uh to assess the emotional
well-being of young people
in their transition year from primary to
secondary education
that so that that's something where uh
the the plume school
piloted for us last year and had some
really good results because
as you can imagine a lot a lot of a lot
of young people
go under the radar and by having this
screening tool
it's only four questions but you know if
people's score
12 or below on this screening tool um
and this has been academically tested
it's it's a useful place for an
intervention
where where the secondary school can
do additional work with that young
person at the transition year
so that that's the first for malden
which uh the meeting this morning we're
looking to roll that out across
the whole of essex um hopefully in the
next
well hopefully this year that we'll see
whether it's achievable to do that
um the only other thing i can say is
about a lot of the multi-agency work we
do
i know at the last meeting dave
could talk about the safe well and
secure work we've done in burnham and
this actually
leads in quite nicely to a very short
video which i'm going to show you
around the tri-party work
which uh the police ambulance service
and fire
are piloting in a dengue peninsula so uh
tara if you could go on to the next
slide and hopefully
the the video will play which is
self-explanatory and then we'll
uh move into mr scott haynes's
presentation and take
questions at the end of both
presentations thank you tara
well we're waiting i am aware that a
number of members are experiencing
internet issues this evening and
dropping in and out of the meetings so
we are aware of this and hopefully
people will be able to catch most of the
meeting
we've lost visuals
that brilliant leslie's back thank you
he's very quiet though spencer
he's very quiet
it's the sounds up as high as i can put
it chairman
i wonder why we've not got sound on the
video
fortunately we have subtitles so so
should we just should we go ahead with
the subtitles members
yeah i think that has to do i think we
will have to won't we
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh we get the uh we got the music at the
end i'm just
very aware that anybody um with a
visual impairment tuning into the
meeting won't have actually been able to
access the content of that so
i'm i'm hoping that they will be able to
actually access it somehow elsewhere
chairman we can put a link on the
website for people if they're interested
we can do that
that would be super thank you very much
sarah thank you um so thank you very
much
um mr clark that was uh that was very
very interesting um
lots of things that appealed to my uh
social workers
head going on there but uh yeah and also
i'm a great fan of multi
agency joining that joined up working as
well as
too much silo working going on so
excellent um members we're going to move
straight to
uh inspector scott haynes presentation
now and then take
questions at the end to uh both mr clark
and mr scott haynes tara do we then vote
on the
um on them both at the end can that work
rather than voting on one now and
and then the other later on chairman you
can do that that's no problem
there is no voting required for um chief
inspector scott haynes oh
spencer's report okay lovely thank you
very very much for that tara so
um yeah members if we can uh hear
inspector scott
haynes chief inspector scott haynes
sorry now and then move on to
questions uh at the end is that
acceptable
i'll take that as a sense so uh over to
you
chief inspector scott haynes thank you
i'm
i'm having some dramas because my boss
is trying to contact me and
covering the whole of my screen
isn't it always the way timing is
absolutely everything
i think everything's set to try us today
so
i think so i can i can see it now right
um i have a presentation which i'm going
to try and share my screen
but as i fall back tara do you have that
presentation if i get it horribly wrong
i have the one that spencer sent this
afternoon yes i have
yeah yeah because at the moment i'm
struggling to get it even to link in as
any chance i could ask you to put it
up yeah of course no problem i'll share
my screen a lot easier
we are beset by the gremlins tonight
aren't we there we go chairman ah thank
you
excellent right thank you very much
right so good evening again i am chief
inspector steve scott haynes so
um obviously i was your community
inspector
up until a year and
five days ago when i was promoted to the
district commander role when um
mr parker left us so um tara can we have
the
next thank you
so i look after the local policing teams
otherwise known as the response teams
based at malden and at chelmsford
um i also have responsibility for the
malden and chelmsford community policing
team including the town centre team
they're based at this time in the
community safety hub over at chelmsford
city council
and the community policing team worked
for the local priorities
of the community safety partnership as
have been explained by mr clark
earlier those teams at this time
although based there
our longer term aim would be to bring
our community team back to malden itself
um that's one of the um things that i've
said and i would like to see put
in place and we're working on that at
the moment if i could have the next
slide please tara so
we work towards the force plan as set by
the um
gentleman top right hand corner our
chief constable
um this plan is set in the
easiest way to look at it is the top
three items to help people
keep people safe and to catch criminals
or as
the chiefs constable likes to say catch
baddies
with our main effort around victims
vulnerability
violence and visibility
the four visas we call it what we like
to
drill into our offices if we are getting
those four v's right
um helping our victims identifying and
helping the vulnerable
dealing with violence and being as
visible as we can in our communities
we should be doing all of the right
things to keep communities safe
and then that's split down into how we
work in our priorities but i won't go
through those all
individually that's what you would
expect so if we can get the next slide
please thank you so the seven policing
priorities to protect essex
which have been agreed through the pcc
or a more local visible and accessible
policing
crackdown on antisocial behaviour
breaking the silent
the cycle silence cycle of domestic
abuse
reverse trend and serious crime tackle
gangs and organize crime
protecting children and vulnerable
people and improve safety
on our roads again
i think these priorities have been in
for quite such a long time most people
are fully aware of them
but if you look at those they're almost
exactly the same as
our 4v's looking after victims
vulnerable reducing violence
and being visible
so we're working towards what the pcc
would like us to do
for the police crime pfcc now sorry
if we can get the next slide please so
performance this is the important bit
this is the bit you guys pay me to
achieve so crime of the moment in modern
area down by 4.9
184 less offenses which is rolling 12
months to february 2021.
it's a similar trend to across um essex
and again it's it's this constant thing
malden's a really safe place so is
chelmsford a really safe place
we still have crime and it's right that
we report on it
unfortunately our anti-social behavior
as we've
all expected to happen has risen
significantly
predominantly down to our covert
breaches um
although high again it's similar as
those across essex
what i'd say again and again is that
we have been so the the people of
essex in general but particularly malden
even more so than chelmsford
have been particularly good at keeping
to the um covered restrictions
it's been particularly well highlighted
obviously everybody's at home so there's
less opportunity to commit crime
um certainly a reduced nighttime economy
rejection
in um dwelling burglaries down something
like 36 percent 100 offenses less
year-on-year which is it's great that's
um 100 people whose houses haven't been
there
invaded which we like to see there are
areas of concern
certainly sexual offenses um
have increased significantly so has
violence without injury
stalking and harassment um
linked to domestic abuse we've seen a
steady increase in our hate crime real
frustrating
frustration that one it seems to be
centered around very minor
areas with repeat
suspects as opposed to victims if that
makes sense so
the repeat person doing it um and
kelly's team are doing some really good
work at work on that
to try and put some um things in place
to stop them from being able to do it
now though we've got percentage rates
really high our actual numbers are
always going to be very very low
um and
any change looks significant
that in some ways helps me because of
its reduction it looks really really
good but if it goes the other way it
looks really really bad
but it's normally very numbers um
future use power bi so business
intelligence power bi i've i've seen
um this new power bi um i'm on something
called the
use of force board for the whole of
essex police
and we got to see this in action for the
first time
it gives me information on stop and
search
everything from ethnicity to breakdown
of
gender to ages
the places it's happening and for the
first time i can break it down between
chelmsford and malden something we've
been trying to do for years
um unfortunately i can't at the moment
share it because it isn't fully online
but as soon as it's fully online
when i come to this panel and the crime
panel i'll be able to share that really
good information
yeah sarah can we get the next slide
please
so impact of covered on policing i've
been a police officer for 20 years i've
never policed like this
it's the strangest thing we've ever had
to deal with um
for us the operational name is called
operation tala
um massive demand on patrolling areas
for
around compliance um
it's been really strange for us because
guidance and laws have changed
significantly
really really quickly and
trying to keep our officers fully up to
speed with what can and can't be done
has been really difficult
even to the point of normally when we
when a new law comes in
it can be challenged in court etc we
haven't even got to the
point where all of these things have
been challenged in court
so i have no doubt some of these things
will change
um overall our crime has reduced during
the pandemic
um has locked down east
we know that crime is going to rise we
absolutely know that will happen
we need to ensure as we come out of
locked iron we have these
effective responses to the reopening of
the town centers
licensing breaches we know at the last
release of the lockdown we had a number
of breaches
around some licensed premises kelly
thurston
and her team did some phenomenal work
closed down
two licensed premises really really
quickly one of those in the malden
district
to stop these things going on um
supporting our vaccination sites that's
setting up across the districts
been quite a big job for us and
supporting obviously our victims of
domestic abuse
with all of that partnership work that
mr clark's already discussed with us
so again next slide please tom thank you
so what's our local community policing
team structure look like
um so detective inspector kelly thurston
taking over from the last chap he i
don't really remember him
we've got three sergeants attached to
the team
um ps david woods and
tembury police sergeant matt dalby who
run the community policing side of it
with nine pcs and 24 pcsos
sorry two to four pcsos
and the town team run by graham thomas
with eight pcs and four pcsos
who cover um chelmsford center
city center malden town centre and
southwood and ferris
town center um that is two officers at
malden
two at southwood and ferris and four
over at chelmsford
also in the team we've had a growth of
our community and
child and young persons officers from
two to four
these are the officers that are working
directly with our youth
offending teams going directly into
secondary schools
liaising with the pastoral staff there
and working directly with children
two mplos which are our missing persons
liaisons officers so these are civilian
workers that help us
where we get a missing person that say
has
repeatedly going mis goes missing
particularly youngsters
the mplos will work with social services
and with
schools etc to try and put something
around
that person to help them stop going
missing
next to cseos and i always get this
wrong
community no i'm going to get it wrong
kelly help me out
you remember what they're called sorry
we had to get off of mute
community support engagement officers
thank you
i always get it wrong so
we have one for you say again
go wisely so
we have one for chelmsford and now
one for malden specifically pc rosie
smith
um her role is to um
look at all of that community engagement
stuff
through social media through meetings
and through newspapers getting our
newsletter out
and basically giving as much information
as we can out to the community show what
we're doing
and one sim pc sim
is a basically this officer looks
works directly with the health service
and we look at people who suffer from
a mental health disorder
which means that they constantly call
police or call ambulance
um we then put a plan around that person
to help them break that cycle of
contacting
emergency services so that we don't
use lots of resources when we we don't
um
we're not really able to assist that
person
so if we can get the next slide please
tara so
our recruitment campaign behind me you
will see fit the bill
value difference um lots of photographs
of um
some of the people that we have looked
to recruit within policing um
really successful campaign to
look at despite dispelling the myths
about you have to be a certain person to
be a police officer
usually white male and british you know
that that that's kind of the thing that
most people think
what we've tried to show is that we
valued um difference predominantly
focusing on the nine strands of
difference from personality age culture
background
ethnicity sexual orientation gender
language education and faith
with the aim of um
increasing the diversity of our own of
essex police um all of the figures that
we get about diversity are really really
difficult because they're based on the
census
which obviously we know is exactly 10
years out of date
so hopefully with the new census we can
show
that actually we're more diverse than we
think we are
but we're looking into that so basically
that
campaign has won some national awards
and um we have already seen that
we are growing with our applications
to almost 10 percent of our applicants
being from an ethnic minority
when we only have three percent
currently as game officers which is
really really good
to see it improving um as we go
tara can we get in the next slide
right so our policing tactics obviously
the community policing responsible for
um specific areas i won't say beats
because i'd um
we we don't use the term beats anymore
to enable officers take control of local
impacts
and being visible and responding to
demand when appropriate and engaging
with our communities
through social media at the moment where
appropriate
but like everybody else we can't wait to
come out of lockdown so we can get face
to face again it's
always better to see a cop face to face
or a pcso
we're trying to be more accessible
street meats coffee with cops all these
things that you've seen before
my local newsletter that i've been
sending out now for three or four months
which
so far has been really well received um
obviously kova has been our big
challenge but facebook live has been
a real surprise for us we get a lot of
people
who probably wouldn't normally attend
meetings
come on and ask us some questions that's
really good to see
um and looking to support our rural
areas
well working with our partners more
through farm
farm watch active citizens rural
engagement team
neighborhood watch which we really need
to push a bit more
we're not quite there at the moment over
in chelsea we've got a really strong
neighborhood watch that's worked really
well for a number of years
and i know that the chair of chelmsford
is more than willing to assist us
to build that up and les who you saw
earlier on from the tribe um
tripartite is going to assist us with
that as well over on the malden side to
try and
build that neighborhood and
there you go now isn't it always away
community safety engagement officers
written in full so i remember it
um pc rosie smith is yours for this area
so can we get the next time tyra so
policing operations
so we're committed to the community
safety hub joint tasking and problem
solving approach
the biggest part of that for me
and the biggest thing that i want to
achieve will be to bring
a community policing team back into
malden
based in malden although our community
policing team officers come out to
malden and they spend as much time in
modern as they do in chelmsford
i really want them to be right in the
hub
of malden itself and i know that
richard is working really hard with our
estates team at the moment
to try and improve the footprint over at
malden council so that we can get more
of our officers here
obviously violent crime and drugs we
still have our operations sector and our
offer operation
overwatch where we try to use our stop
and search powers
um to detect drugs and weapons
obviously in the correct way using go
wisely councillor morris so that we do
that right
vulnerability we look at through our
operation enlightenment through our
schools
opera and henderson through transport
hubs
that also gets us going and speaking to
people like taxi drivers hoteliers
so that we can identify vulnerable
people coming to into the area
and give hoteliers taxi drivers people
like that the tools they need
to actually pick up the phone and tell
us because they see these things
and aren't always sure how to progress
it and obviously we'll look at any local
issues
through specific operations which are
linked to
that area or a particular problem that's
identified to us
whether that's drug dealing whether
that's
vehicle problems through asb um
whether that's a prolific shoplifter
turns up in modern it could happen
um so we'll look at any operation and
try to progress it
tara i think that was the last slide
there you go um excellent
thank you very much thank you very much
um chief inspector and also thank you
very much for providing the um
police numbers figures for us uh earlier
on i know they were quite difficult
to get hold of so many things very close
as soon as i can get hold of the um
actual recruit numbers which as of yet
haven't come through
i'll ensure that they come to the board
so that you're aware of them
superb thank you very much for that
really helpful and
very positive news about um about
the local team in moulton so you know
looking looking up to optimistic and we
really appreciate i think i speak for
everyone when i say
how much we appreciate the difficulties
and challenges
of responding to covid and
and the changes in in the way policing
happens
uh that you've that you've had to make
so with us he said no notice and no kind
of
uh leading period at all so it's been an
interesting time i'm sure it has
yes that's an old chinese proverb i
think isn't it
you live in interesting times but so
members sir now if uh
i can go to the recommendation that
members review and comment on the
current progress of the initiatives
undertaken by the partnership that was
uh what spencer talks about
to date and no the strategic priorities
for 2021-22
would anyone like to second that motion
don't all speak at once counsellor
fleming seconded
thank you councillor fleming um so
now if i can take
questions to both the champion inspector
scott haynes
and mr clark do any members have any
questions councillor fleming i can see
your hand
thank you chair i had a couple of
questions for
spencer about the public space
protection order
i wanted to know um
what sort of questions the consultation
asks
because i i haven't seen it um is it on
the council website
um yeah i just would like to know a bit
more about that
because i think i understand that
they've been around for a while so
my question is is why now um
and what sort of because it i understand
it's
for a geographical area and what sort of
um things will be you know banned
if you like
good questions okay yes so uh
public space protection orders so so the
rules changed a few years ago so we we
used to have what's called a designated
public place order um for the promenade
but it never extended further up into
the high street in other areas
so um the whole purpose of the
consultation which
i've been working with damien giller and
liam liam payment on
is that um everyone will have an
opportunity to comment
uh in the consultation there'll be a
map of the area shown uh we'll be
writing
to all of the relevant partners involved
as well as
retail such as pubs all of the shops in
the
uh high street uh all of the traders in
the prom
you know so every everyone we can solve
it everyone will have the opportunity to
say things
what it what it will do it will give the
police and the council
more powers to tackle people who
are are drinking in their anti-social
behavior
if that's such a such a way we're not
we're not looking to target
people were sitting on the prom having
their champagne with a few strawberries
it's when they start hitting each other
on the head with the bottles etcetera is
when we
need to start making that intervention
uh and also
particularly since uh um
in the first lockdown um when it first
eased in the summer
um there was days when promenade park
was awash with nitrous oxide canisters
um so it's something we've used
effectively before in chelmsford
um where we've uh we used it for
four years running at the v festival so
we only actually had
a public place perception protection
order in for two weeks running
just to prevent drug use during the
festival
so so it can be used you know in a
proportionate manner we're not looking
to
sort of uh you know challenge people
on their you know what we just want is
to be people to behave in an appropriate
manner and so that everybody can enjoy
those areas
everyone can enjoy the high street
everyone can enjoy the prom they'll just
give us those extra powers to deal with
it
um yeah so that it can be used in other
manners i know uh
um i think debian girl has got his hand
up he's been leaking
so chair would it be okay if i invite
damien to say a few words about this
particular project
you took the words out of my mouth there
mr clark
so mr gayle would you like to go ahead
thank you councillors um hopefully
you'll be able to hear me properly i i
know that there's been
uh some problems with the internet um so
yes
just really to to come back on what
spencer's been saying
um the public space protection order is
literally a set of
conditions or rules on a given area we
all know that
um we've got a defined map at the minute
and the purpose of the consultation is
to one um
check that the conditions are right for
the area because we we come up with the
conditions based on policing
evidence in terms of uh drug use in a
particular area
and alcohol related nuisance in a
particular area so that's how we that's
how it helps to find the map
um if it's felt that the map needs to be
extended or shortened at the end of the
public consultation period then that's
what will happen because we use the
consultation to form
the public space protection order going
forward and once in place it lasts for a
period of up to three years that's the
intention with this one
um most large town centres have a public
space protection order of some sort
and it's not the it's not meant to be
um the immediate go-to to solve
anti-such behavior it's it's like um an
additional tool to be used to control
anti-social behavior in an area
so in terms of alcohol consumption
consuming alcohol as has been said
isn't anti-social um it's when
um the behavior surrounding it starts to
become
become anti-social so if someone is um
becoming entertained because they're
drunk then we can ask them to surrender
their alcohol
if they refuse to surrender the alcohol
then it becomes something that we can
choose to enforce against
and the enforcing partners are either
the police or um
the council officers certain council
officers
and as i said it's really just to try
and control and encourage better
behavior
um some of the other antisocial behavior
powers we got take
time to embed and the idea with this is
it's more of a quick hit
to try and stop the behavior dead in
this tracks before it becomes you know a
bit more established
um and yes the the other
it does relate to illegal drugs and
psychoactive substances which includes
nitrous oxide canisters
um as we all know um the issue with
nitrous oxide canisters is that they're
quite
cheap easily available um and
you can buy that they're legal to buy
because obviously they're used for
cooking
but they get used for other other
purposes and that's when they become a
problem
and so the idea about being able to
enforce against it is something i think
that the um
we need in our town center areas um so
yes we we've had some initial uh
internal uh consultations we're now
ramping up to move to external
consultation that'll last for six weeks
at the end of the six weeks we gather
all the results in we'll be going
through all of it to take on board
everyone's comments and then it will
come back out in a finalized form for
final
um notifications and then it's the hard
way
trying to get all the uh the signage and
the implementation in place provided
it's accepted
thank you um damian thank you very much
and i know we have enormous problems
with nitrous oxide canisters in burnham
and riverside park
so uh that'd be very helpful for us as
well i think council fleming does that
answer your question
yes thank you vanessa um
that's great lovely i will go to
councillor morley first followed by
councillor bassinger and then councilman
morris so councillor morley please
uh yes thank you chair um just really an
intriguing one how
how do you cope with the scam calls and
things like that
probably to spence really with i get
one or two people ask me who do they
report obviously reported to the police
but
it must be a minefield and how do you go
about
sourcing the you know the source of the
problem really
thank you
mr clerk thank you councillor morley uh
we we've actually uh
i think i don't know if it's happened
yet we've actually got a uh
training event for neighborhood watch on
scams in the very near future
um so that that's one of the areas been
looking at and
um i think one of the areas you know
we've all heard about the
scams which have been coming about the
vaccine and everything you know people
have been
charged trying to charge our elderly
folk
for for you know so it is a minefield
there is a i think there's a new unit
essex police is actually
dealing with these particular business
units dealing with a lot of the business
scams etc
but um i know there is a if if this
session hasn't happened i know we had a
booked in session for neighborhood watch
which is a
training event on scans so what what
i'll do is i'll try and share that with
members
um so that they've got an opportunity to
that because i know i know claire and my
team's uh
uh was was arranged we're arranging that
so that you know if we if we can
upskill all of the local coordinators
and they can cascade that information
onto other
other members of the public that'd be
really useful but yes you quite rightly
said
it it's very fluid the sooner you tackle
one there's another one around the
corner as you can imagine
so hey keep up with it but um i don't
know
you start to even go where it comes from
because it's only a phone number and
these poor pensioners and people like
that or vulnerable people
are swallowed in with it and it's so sad
but thank you thank you
thank you um that's the passenger please
thank you chair um this is a question
really for
uh mr clark i think um in your
presentation there was a there was a
line which was
i think it was conspiracy and domestic
radicalization
i i mean it kind of makes me feel a bit
uncomfortable i just wondered
if you can define that and what that
actually means
so as i explained this part of the
discussion earlier i sit on the 60 which
is a
special interest group encounter
extremism and uh
when when we when we instantly think
about
extremism uh people tend to think about
um
the islamic influence towards it which
it has been over the years
um but the risk the risk to essex
um if you if you look at it i mean we
only last
week we had our counterterrorism local
profile
is other types of groups whether
they're where you can call them far
right you can call them civic
nationalist
type groups but there's been a lot a lot
of
issues in essex we've experienced some
in chelmsford
epping have had quite a lot of issues
around the bowel hotel
etc um where um
where the home office have been housing
migrants in the bell hotel
and it seems to be causing lots of
community tensions
um so like because we're in a lockdown
situation a lot of this information is
put over the internet over community
facebook groups etc
so so that's that's what i mean about um
domestic extremism but one of the
worrying things
is how young i mean i'm not
a lot of young men 15 16 17 year olds
are accessing quite extreme material
online
and we only had an incident um just
after christmas in uh
in chelmsford where a young 17 year old
boy
was uh arrested on neo-nazi charges
you know we i mean you don't expect you
know you
say don't expect you you know you never
expect it to happen in in
your particular town or village so we
know that's happening we know there's
more of an influence you've got
young people sitting at home bored in
lockdown
uh you know look at information they
shouldn't do and in some circumstances
these people becoming
radicalized so that's that's when i say
increasing domestic extremism i mean if
you look at on a more
more international platform if you look
at someone you know like the q anon
group
you know in the storming of the capital
in the states uh
recently you know that you you look at
that sort of information
going around but but more importantly
and i
had this discussion with the chair a few
weeks ago about
the the psychological impact on those
people who subscribe to these sort of
conspiracy theories
it's having a massive impact and
coventry university done quite a lot of
uh
um studies on that and
how that can impact young people and the
influence not just young people
how it can impact on other people so
that's what when i say about
the sort of domestic extremism i mean
things like conspiracy theories i mean a
prime example is the vaccine you know
with the sort of information
going out about the vaccine at the
moment if you if you look at it look at
it on the internet i mean i only watched
a problem on the
program on the bbc iplayer the other
night about how
um four professionals had
sent videos to older folk telling them
why they shouldn't take the vaccine
and yeah you know these are people who
are who are
either serving or suspended doctors now
you know so that that sort of
information
and when we're trying to encourage as
many communities i mean having the
vaccine is a choice for people
don't get me wrong but when we're trying
to convince people
um you know particularly from some of
their
um other other types of groups i mean i
i i speak
to a our independent advisory group
where we have a really good
attendance from the the jewish community
uh the muslim community chinese
community
but one of the groups who show quite a
lot of
mistrust in authority particularly the
government is the black african
community
and a lot of them are saying that they
do not want to take the vaccine because
of mistrust
you know so so that's just an example of
conspiracy theories but
there's lots going round so i think it's
just important that we
we keep an eye on what's happening
locally but also nationally
on on those sort of areas so that's what
we're doing as a part of that
uh special interest group to try and
monitor such tensions and
more importantly what what sort of
counter narrative you can have
to those sort of discussions so it's
because sometimes
staying quiet isn't the right thing to
do so i hope hopefully that gives you a
good good idea what i'm trying to
explain there
thank you spencer i know you and i had a
discussion about how one
is quite alarming the way that the far
right is using covid to radicalize
people particularly as spencer said um
you know young young men but
and the vaccine misinformation i
understand completely mistrust amongst
certain communities i mean there are
certain
communities who have in the past been
experimented on
you know and all kinds of horrific
things have have happened
so you know it's about educating people
i've
had my first vaccine and there's no sign
of the crocodile crocodile tail yet
so uh i think uh we're gonna be okay
there so
thank you very much if i could go first
councilor morris then back
to uh councillor fleming again
councillor morris
thank you chair um i'd just like to
quickly say that i would
enjoy it having a uh conversation with
spencer about the vaccine stuff
um i think that the the biggest mistrust
that the vaccine brings is that it's got
no liability for the manufacturers
did you know that spencer
no i didn't sound slow morris but i'd
say
for for the manufacturers of the vaccine
and um
you know obviously i would expect you to
tell me not to use a uh a cab
for instance if it wasn't insured
wouldn't you so
uh perhaps if there was some liability
for the vaccine there'd be a lot more
people willing to take it
um i'll get back to uh my original one
going back to the
psp thank you but spencer might mean
you're gonna have a chat about that
because i can't wait to hear what your
uh you know what your your tactics will
be
to uh try and talk me around common
sense i was about to
interject councillor morris though i
suggest you take that conversation
outside but not
in the way that other people might
assume i mean that
no no no no there'll be no fisticuffs
between me and spencer we love each
other too dearly
um pspos i would just like to know that
uh
once the pspos start coming into our
district
are we going to be using um private
companies
uh to to basically uh get the um
uh penalty charge uh i think it's a
penalty charge now it's in isn't it
is it a pcn uh sorry um
fpm that a uh
pspo would generate and would that be
a buyer a private company that would be
incentivized and have been accused of
profiteering
um by issuing um fixed penalty notices
for the pspos i mean there's been some
absolutely ridiculous psbos
introduced by other councils um one of
them for instance is a psbo
that uh people can't use the toilet for
any length of time
they're asked to leave the toilets
quickly
and stuff like that i mean there's you
know i've got some other ones
um there is for instance um
warnings um issued for um
picking up casual laborers and stuff
like that now
if we're going to use psbo's we need to
make sure they're sensible
and are they going to be you know
enforced
by private security companies and the
like
spencer i agree
they used they need to be used in a
proportionate manner
um most uh
fixed penalty continuous which are
issued paid
to the council or the police uh quite
promptly
i can't answer that question about
private security companies
uh being used uh to do collections
uh it's not something which uh yeah i
don't
i i'm not sure sure that's the right
thing to do uh
what i will say is where where we've
used them in uh
chelmsford and we've been using we've
had a pspo in champs with high street
for
six and a half years now and again that
that that is probably
primarily around alcohol
but i think the public consultation is
really important
because we have to listen to our public
in champs because one of
one of the issues we we have had in
charge is around
uh begging and aggressive begging
so we actually changed the word in
following the public consultation
for that so it's important the con
consultation stage is
very important um but what we've tended
to do is
you know like right he said issue a
warning first
you know issuing a warning is always the
first step having that
form of intervention whether it be the
police
whether it be a community engagement
officers whether it's even a chat with a
youth service if we're doing
detached youth work in the park for
example
you know we shouldn't see it as a as a
stick
we should see it as a positive
intervention tool
and i think that's right yeah and we
should only get to that stage of
issuing fines in extreme cases i think
so you know so so let's uh i think
damien wants to come in there
i think damian wants to help you out
here spencer i think councilman before
damien for you coming the key is to
encourage as many people as possible to
take part in the consultation
because uh my understanding is that will
ask quit
ask about the areas and the things you
think should
be covered by the pspo so uh
make sure that as many people as
possible in your world take part in that
consultation if you can
um damien i'll come to you now please
thank you
um just really to to answer those
queries so um
the conditions that we've chose if you
like standard conditions that you'll
find
within many pspos um because that type
of behavior does go on in town centers
you know i i've i've i've applied for
town centres in other areas and yes
you're right you know
there's a whole host of conditions you
can try and put in there that's not the
intention with this it's literally to
tackle
bad behavior not to try and do anything
sort of um
off the wall if you like or or um
experimental
um in terms of the fixed penalty notice
um
it literally just be the police and the
ceo officers
uh and our well the police and our own
council officers
there won't be any external agents that
we're bringing in for this
good thank you thank you very much thank
you um
councillor fleming i see you have is
that a legacy hand or a new hand
it is a new hand new hand go ahead
councillor fleming
uh so i had a question for the chief
inspector
and then another one for uh spencer
i wanted to ask ask the chief inspector
has the backlog in the courts had any
impact on on your work
right so um the directly
know in that our cases are still going
forward
um we are still completing our files
they go off to cps cps then push them up
through the courts
um it is meaning days longer before
we're getting into court
um i know that some of our really
serious cases talking to my colleagues
in the
in the major investigation teams are
looking sort of
12 months before they're going to get a
court date so there is going to be a
backlog there but that backlog is
further down the line than my officers
are dealing with
that being said we um did do
an operation i believe it was two months
ago i might be a little bit wrong on the
timing
where we had to provide extra officers
to the court
to try and experiment where they were
pushing more cases through very quickly
um to allow the backlog to be reduced
there may be similar to that come when
we come out of lockdown
that had a direct impact on the
community policing team because they had
to provide an officer
to be there all of the time during the
court to do the running for the
community
for the cps etc but one officer
for one week wasn't the biggest impact
we've ever had
okay thank you um and then my question
to spencer um you mentioned pedestrian
accounts and traffic counts from the
cctv
um how extensive was that did you do
over a week or
and and how do you have that data
yes we the government were issued
particular times and dates
when we were to do the pedestrian
accounts so that information
was supplied by based on those
particular days
i think there was a tuesdays and
saturdays and at certain times of the
day
so it just gave them a rich picture of
how many people were on the high street
at that particular time so that that's
what that that was and we have we do
have that data which can be
uh yeah by all means uh it's not not
sensitive in any way because it's
you know it doesn't identify anywhere if
you see what i mean
so uh it will just be numbers
effectively so
other things we've been looking at is uh
vehicle flow movements etc
um and uh one of the other areas we're
looking at is uh
um heavy goods lorries use at market
hill
uh was another area we were doing a
survey for so it's been quite
quite useful because it's you know
rather than it just
when everyone thinks about cctv they
think about crime and disorder all the
time but
it can be really useful for other other
factors i mean
i didn't expect to be monitoring a
autumn storm surge
on high of key using cctv but just by
putting a board up with the
with the with the depths and everything
enabled us to do that so
rather than having an officer out at two
o'clock in the morning checking it
we're able to do that and relay that
information back to the environment
agency
great thank you spencer so uh sorry chad
are you going
to do future traffic and pedestrian
accounts as well
yes by all means if if if that
information if the information is
requested by
the moulding moulding council or essex
county council highways we're more than
happy to do that
because it's you know it's a it's a
really genuine use for cctv isn't it
you know because rather than paying
someone to sit in the car of a little
clicker
doing it we can we can either do that
live or or we can do it by retrieving
the evidence which goes back for a
calendar month so yes yes we can do that
yeah thank you lovely thank you
i'll go to councillor bassinger again
and then councillor morley councillor
passenger police
this is a question for chief inspectors
you said that we no longer use the word
beat
i mean i just think that most people can
they're really really in visual presence
on the streets i mean you're breaking up
counsellor passenger it might be an idea
if you turn your camera off and try
again because
we didn't catch that
just just i don't know i just wanted to
need any moves to get to the vision
um i mean perhaps you could uh if you
could email your question and then i
could make sure that it gets forwarded
to
to the right person would that be okay
thank you um councillor morley then
councilman morris
yeah thank you justin um inquisitive one
really to the chief inspector thank you
um was it nosewood with the lockdown
with burglaries
as everyone's at home being in and
have you had any challenges with all the
premises are in lockdown with
vandalism or burglaries all the pubs
factory or not perhaps factories but
things being shut down and people
breaking in
out of interest thank you yeah
um so dwelling burglary burglary of
people's houses
massively reduced because people are at
home
um that that has seen a a massive
reduction
um the the
only area of burglary that we have seen
continue
not increase or decrease but continue
it's normal
at the level we've been seeing before
lockdown is what we call a millennium
burglary
which is where um a house is broken into
specifically to take car keys and to
take a vehicle
and that has remained probably on a
level hasn't hasn't increased hasn't
decreased but overall burglary has
um and no not really we haven't really
had business premises burgled
to a higher degree um it's amazing
you know it's it surprised us it's the
same as um
we really expected domestic
um assaults to skyrocket at times and it
hasn't
any domestic assault is wrong don't get
me wrong and we don't want any of them
but we really expected a massive
increase that we didn't see we know
there are reporting issues around that
and we know that
um unfortunately uh abusers are still
with
their victims which hopefully will see
those victims coming forward once um
things have eased up a bit
but no exactly the areas i would have
expected
with an increase in criminal damage and
increase
in people breaking into places like you
know a warehouse etcetera
no really haven't seen that increase uh
increase
so very surprising yeah okay
thank you thank you councilman morris
i'm going to you and then i'm afraid i
have a whole heap of questions
for both the chief inspector and mr
clark so
councillor morris see you please thank
you
um just a guy uh to start off um i'd
like to
thank the chief inspector for his help
over the past few weeks you and your
um your lads and lassies have been very
very professional i thank you for that
um i was just wondering uh chief
inspector um nationally there is quite a
bit of a problem
with um the sickness and attendance of
officers uh both for stress related and
coveted
how is that impacting essex police and
uh
you know this district's policing
okay so um from the data that i've been
able to um get so far on this on average
we lose
around five days per year per
officer in um essex
chelsea and malden are on exactly the
same level as that
at the moment just slightly lower than
the essex average
but it's it's really tiny little bit
lower
um yes we have had um issues
coved has not been as
big of an issue as we thought it would
be that being said the one area where we
did have a major problem
some weeks ago we had a whole shift here
at malden
so one of my local policing teams
the whole shift um did test positive
um thank goodness they're all back to
work they're all
well again and um getting on with their
job
kelly thurston um my cpt inspector
i picked the right week i was on leave
on the week this happened
so kelly got to manage it all for me and
put some really good work in to get a
real deep clean done in the council
offices and everything so
we have had a case where we've taken out
a whole shift
for um one set of shifts
but um we backfilled from chelmsford so
hopefully the public didn't really see a
difference in the policing over
that period well it's lucky that the uh
tests are only seven percent accurate
thank you
councillor morris and i do want to say
actually i'm
chief inspector i do want to offer my
condolences for
your marine officer who we sadly lost to
clovid so
uh condolences for for that that was
very very sad
so questions from
my colleagues um
first of all well i think this is to uh
youtube inspector
when are you going to install the
emergency public telephone at the
council offices i understand this has
been
ongoing
i've waited so long to say that
oh that's brilliant yes that's
in place and the council very graciously
put in an extra piece of um paving so
that
the public can go up there without
getting damn feet as well so yeah it's
in place it has already been used a
number of times so
um yes we're there at last i can't
believe i've said so much about the
phone
[Laughter]
tap on the window though
thank you very much chief inspector um
the next one is also
for you um how successful have you been
in addressing the public perception of
no visible policing
well you're pretty visible in burnham
last night um
what measures have you introduced and
will you introduce in the future to
continue the improvements that have been
made and within what time frame
i know you've mentioned some of the
initiatives that have been going on with
um you know things like coffee with cops
but
i guess the co covid
um has stopped and we've done a lot of
work around
our um our social media footprint print
put my teeth back in footprint to try
and increase getting some of the good
news stories out
letting people know where we are i've
very deliberately asked the officers
to take photographs of where they are
and get that out on social media to
physically show
because with all the will in the world
not everyone is going to see my officers
when they're out because that's just not
what happens we know that
we absolutely know that so particularly
using the
the social media platforms i've asked
them to take photograph and take a
photograph of the street name they're in
take iconic um locations within whether
that's burn and whether that's malden
so that we can show people we're
actually physically there
where we identify an issue whether
that's antisocial behavior
whether that's drug dealing
when the officers are out there again
it's showing we have been there
physically showing we've been there
where we can and where the member of the
public is happy for us to
knocking on the door and saying we're
here
and we don't get it right 100 of the
time we can't i wish we could
but we we will always be there um
i've started putting out this newsletter
this monthly newsletter
again it's getting that out to a wider
audience
because not everyone has social media
giving some of the information around
what we're doing and why we're out there
um i'm trying to get some livery changes
to our vehicles
so that we can show that we are doing
rural patrols as well as
city patrols um it's it's
i know that sometimes it can feel that
malden is the sort of second
yeah second best to chelmsford because
chelmsford's bigger
um that is bernard is third
best chief inspector nowhere near third
madam chairman you wouldn't allow me to
do that
um i should hope so indeed getting our
community team
back out on the ground there um we've
done a lot of work
at burnham police station and getting
the marine unit back there
and i know that chief inspector darren
deeks has been really really
um interested in making sure that the
presence is felt there of the marine
unit and we'll continue that
um the tri-service through layers
obviously more of that
and lock down the release of lockdown
hopefully will take us away from some of
those covey duties
to be back out there talking to people
face to face again
um i know the community guys miss that i
know the pcsos missed that
and we want to be out there doing it um
as we get more officers we will build
the size of the community team
and get more people out there um i've
said that from the day i arrived here
and i've always tried to push that
that's
that's what we really want to do
our last survey results that we did as
essex police
have shown a real increase in how
the people of malden are seeing what
we're doing and for the first time
year on year i showed an increase right
across the board
and that's that's for me says right
we're getting there we're doing the
right things
um what i've always aimed for is that we
do like a couple of percentage points
you know one or two percent but keep it
there all the way through
and that will went horribly wrong this
time around because we had an increase
of 10
that means i've got to keep it up
no thank you that's that's that's really
helpful and i have to say i
i i have noticed in burnham over recent
months i have
whether it's that there are fewer people
around i don't know but i don't think so
i have noticed that i have been
police patrols around so thank you very
much for that
um next one i'm sorry i'm putting you on
the spot
here chief inspector rather petty crime
is
on the increase but residents continue
not to report it as they say it's a
complete waste of time
as the police won't come to the scene or
speak to the person who reported it
what do you think you could do to
address this this perception
right so petty crime there's no such
thing as a petty crime
it's as simple as that there's no such
thing as a petty crime a crime as a
crime
thank you for that um thank you
unfortunately we can't be everywhere all
of the time and we can't always
um do everything for
every crime if if we get a
let's say a some criminal damage is
committed to
a property and there is no witness
no cctv
no way of identifying someone
it is highly unlikely i'm going to send
a police officer to it
we'll record the crime we'll put the
crime on to the system
and we'll ensure that we send out
literature
etc because even
an officer turning up is not going to
change the outcome of that
unfortunately
where there is the potential of a
witness
cctv a named suspect
or a a description of a suspect
a police officer will attend um
it it's it's demand at the end of the
day
it is about demand and we can't
do absolutely everything that we would
love to do
that we we often hear
that when we had a village bobby
yeah that bobby would know everything
and
yes they probably did know everything
and they probably did know everyone
unfortunately policing has changed
communities have changed it's not
as much like that as it used to be um
but we now record everything back when i
started this job 20 years ago
you know if there was no hope of the
crime being solved
it probably wasn't recorded so
now we are where we're more honest
i'm sure councillor morris will keep us
that way
thank you thank you
chase inspector um
i just noticed looking at the figures
that they think there does seem to be
a bit of a a drop in the solve rates
which is a little bit
concerning is there is there a
particular
reason for that trend chief inspector
right so um solve rates unfortunately do
go up and down which is one of those
it's a real frustration so what we are
trying to do
is specifically look at different types
of outcomes
which are not always recorded as a
solved rate
so a solve rate's really really easy
isn't it so
i i am somebody steals something
i arrest that person i put them before a
court
um at that point it is decided that i've
solved the crime
it could go to court and they could be
found not guilty
but it's recorded that i've solved the
crime okay
um what we are trying to do is use
different types of outcomes
through community resolutions through
having victims and suspects sit down and
talk to each other
which do not show as the same resolution
does that make sense the restorative
justice
stuff so they don't
always show as a solved crime in the
same way
so although there is a reduction some of
that is due to changes through that
some of that is um
we had a really difficult month so a a
month ago
at malden
it showed that we had not solved
any um domestic abuse cases
at standard risk we put them at standard
medium and high risk
and quite rightly the depth chief
counsel asked me to explain why that
happened
i reviewed the cases and it was right we
hadn't solved any of them and there were
good reasons for that
but i also pointed out that maldon still
has the highest solved rate
of the whole of essex and it was a
one-month blip
so there are blips in general
particularly around malden
we tend to solve far more crimes
than we do in other areas of the count
of the county
and that's because the community are so
much more willing to tell us what's
going on
and that's what we have to keep pushing
and remembering
and making sure we are doing the right
thing for the community
brilliant thank you and lastly um
you will be relieved to hear me i
don't know i i don't know if this is
possible i know we've discussed
previously that concerning um
increasing sexual offenses but also how
some of this might in fact be reporting
of historical
instances is there any way of separating
out the figures chief inspector so that
we can
so that we know which is reporting of
historical offences
and which and how many offenses that are
taking place now
is that feasible to separate those
figures in that way
right so where wherever we can
put an actual date or a date
range in place um that would be recorded
historically and would show historically
unfortunately with a lot of historical
offenses
what happens is we we we just have a
range of
how do you put this i was sexually
assaulted
yeah during a period of time
yeah and i don't remember what that is
so at that point we have to record it
for that year
so certainly if i because this this is
something we looked at quite recently
um when we look at the offenses
that have been recorded unfortunately
offences against children
um 22
of the 69 offenses that we had we know
were historical
um and it does show the figure
differently it does make it look
that we've got a worse problem than we
have but unfortunately
right now there's no way for us to
change that
i i suspected as much i thought that was
probably the case but
thanks ever so much for clarifying that
for me so
well thank you members does anybody else
have
any further questions
i think you're off the hook spencer and
the chief inspector thank you again very
much and
thank you inspector first and also
damian thank you for
for your input tonight so i think
that takes us to the
um recommendation that we
uh agree to um
the review and commenting so uh members
can we do that
by ascent to uh agree to the progress of
yeah agreed
that's fantastic thank you very much
thank you
so um i don't have any other items of
business that
are urgent so unless i have forgotten
anything which i'm sure
tara will advise me on if i have
that brings us to the closure of the
meeting so members officers and
guest contributors thank you very much
for your con
for your contributions and i now draw
the meeting to a close
at 7 43 p.m as the meeting is now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussion on this forum and
to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you and good night good evening